he's setting up his cards I start
opening up these boxes and stuff we got
wizard of I and Catwoman toys brick yes
there were juniors in high school when
it looks over hey oh I know this
[Music]
please
[Music]
the book I'm coming out with early next
year is called crushed it it's a follow
up and the reason I'm doing it is you're
right man like there's like I don't
think I ever want to get too far away
from there's a real correlation between
doing things around your favorite things
it's just easier when [ __ ] is bad like
I'm looking forward to the Owen sixteen
jet season like like I really think that
everybody who's listening has been
passionate about some sort of thing in
their lives something whether it was
Atari these adubato show classic New
York personality a little bit of a
gloomy day here in New York got a bunch
of interesting meetings feeling really
Brooksie have a Pokemon if you read
crusher no.9 and you decided to build
the blog which later became the video
blog which later became the podcast
about Pokemon a lot of people that was
like a era where Pokemon was in the
culture but not too crazy just Pokemon
right if you became the foremost Pokemon
gal Sally the Pokemon gap and you just
owned it and you're just getting by you
had to have a side job but you can go to
comic-con you show up it shows you can
get on occasional weird $500 sponsorship
on your blog when you were a good
business person and you actually made a
little bit more and you're trucking
along and then Pokemon go comes out and
you're now on CNN and on Fox and in all
these places and now you're going to pay
five thousand dollars to give a talk
about it like you'd of what the world
would have walked into you instead of
you walking to where the money is
everybody's listening right now is
looking for trends all these spinners
are cool they're trying to walk to where
the world is now and by the time they
get there the world moved on if you go
to your thing and set a [ __ ] flag on
your thing I genuinely believe that
there's a lot of moments where the world
comes to you every kid I grew up with
who got talked out of playing video
games because they had to be a doctor or
lawyer by their parents could have had
the talent to make ten million dollars
or being an eSports star but in 1988 to
1993 who the hell needs a plummet
amazing Oh a night crushing of that yeah
we'll do something we'll do something oh
thank you thank you thank you thank you
thank you kicking back enjoy see I heard
it all before
day no not over what's in store this is
a hit and I'll make more now come
knocking on my door random thought
something I've been very passionate
about what snapchat is there non
adjustment to something that I think is
very important which is what Facebook
has done in their environment on
Facebook Instagram is given users the
option to be able to do all forms of
content short long long video short
video written pictures I think that the
platforms have merged into each other
right Facebook has merged into where
YouTube and snapchat has played and
become a complete publishing content
infrastructure and I think for anybody
that's going to compete at the highest
levels independently whether it's Google
or Apple or snapchat or anybody else
Amazon anybody out or somebody who
emerges tomorrow the next snapchat or
Instagram they're going to have to get
flexibility to the users I think you
start with something narrow and then you
build on top of it I think we forget
that you start with something narrow and
you build on top of it
McDonald's had three products when they
started you know a drink fries and a
burger and I think that you know feature
from Instagram a picture and a filter is
great and I think snapchat was
incredible which is why a contraction
but I do think that there's a maturity
level it's kind of the way I think about
vaynermedia what we did with 30 people
culturally output changes at 80 changes
at 800 I think people hold on to things
romantically
got them there without realizing the
thing that's going to get into the next
level is to break the thing that got
them there and so I have no insight into
it with snapshots thinking about more
flexibility but I'm sitting here so I
had the thought I want to do some
content for snapchat but it's like a
little flexibility I love what I can do
there when the consumers have an
alternative and that's what stories in
Instagram have done for them I think you
need to build out like you know I want
to make a six minute video for snapchat
right now I do something to think about
in a macro I used to snapchat example of
the framework for the back row which is
please don't allow yourself to not
evolve on top of the thing that guides
you there I believe that there's very
good entrepreneurs in the market and I
do believe that their apps and
businesses are under priced because
they're in the market of Dublin and so I
think that's an opportunity it's not
that I'm this great noble American
entrepreneur to be fair to everybody in
Dublin it's because I actually think I
could get a good deal because I think
people do underestimate other parts of
the world not mean Silicon Valley that's
correct
when you filled a lot of differences
they don't impact your future businesses
right if I build Starbucks
I wasn't going to be able to build like
Celine what Ivan
to build something that is useful for me
in other inclusive behaviors and that
excites me and I think I'm on my way I
like attention like I'm so you know
flattering it is to take a selfie
I like all that but I also like when you
talk and a lot of people listen it
allows you as a talker to listen because
we get a lot of feedback and I learned
from my community every day I get
consumer insights at scale I have a week
there's a week listen like I said back
to we were just talking about eventually
the work is going to prove itself like I
didn't fight accident invest in Twitter
Facebook Tumblr uber snapchat before a
lot of other people even knew it existed
that is not by accident
I didn't buy I mean this is something
nobody talks about because it's lost in
history
I didn't by accident bet the farm on
Australian Spanish and New Zealand wines
when nobody else was doing that right
I'm not I'm not hanging out with these
influencers and up-and-coming hip-hop
celebrities and artists for kicks and
giggles it's not happening by accident
I think to your point the thing that I
like is I've noticed a lot of times
brands humans add more fire by jumping
in so I do think trading it
I think being prepared for whatever the
response if there's momentum back to us
being concerned about it is important
but I think watching it every second and
and and ironically I do believe 9 out of
every 10 times I mean the new cycles in
our society today are stunningly short
which like the man rang great awesome hi
happy to be on so I'm an entrepreneur
born in Belarus in the former Soviet
Union came to the US when I was three I
think quality is actually tied up in
people's ego right I think people like
to think they know and so quality
subjective right like I love the glasses
you're wearing right now by the way what
a quick compliment others may not and so
things are subjective right and so I
value speed over quality because quality
of fake before it goes out and speed
isn't I'm not sure to be honest what I
would say is this though you have no
option
patience is practical like what are you
gonna do like you know it's going to
play out the way it's going to play out
like and I would also say try to put
yourself in a position to do what you
love right like I feel like I'm a so in
love with the process of being an
entrepreneur that I'm even I slowing
down my financial impact because I love
it right I love holding out for it it's
you know I often make the joke like I
love I love the four
play of entrepreneurship right like it's
a long process like I love that you know
it's I love it so much I wanted to last
forever
I secretly don't want to buy the Jets
right because I feel like the game that
I put out in front of me would then be
accomplished so you know I think that I
think that loving what you do allows you
to love the process which then allows
you to be massively patient if you're
doing this because you want a million
dollars you know yeah yeah yeah I
possessed day one yeah being on a
mission to get these people what they
want up they are eating item lining up
like lunch right about coming in number
twos I'm making number one one Jen they
got really real I'm like really good
they CompTIA 155 of my heart ways of
[ __ ] sign charge highly anticipated
only [ __ ] be when I help you picture
me falling off you can you find our way
right so let's have John Kay branded you
and Danny here in my office for 30 in
not next week with the following week we
should also give up we should also make
a Facebook commercial you take the lead
with Brandon and Andy let's get it done
but I want like let's get something
bigger to add cool first artists it was
just I remember you know alright let's
go do it
now what's it gonna cost me what's the
family discount weather that bias is
true or not here's what I can tell you
there's never been an ad agency and
that's what we are we just happen to
look the part of something a little bit
different is that is more committed to
the end result than this company and I
think that if you peel away a lot of
what's going on a lot of what's
manifested I do not believe nor anybody
decided this I think this is human
behavior of running businesses over the
long term
the thought that there are humans that
work at these agencies that have the
audacity to think that they've
synthesized the proper strategy and then
they are the unique couple of human
beings that get to interpret it because
it is 100 percent humanly subjective and
then they are the same another group of
human beings within that same
organization are the ones that get to
interpret the insights and strategy into
a creative output and that the cost
associated that and the distribution of
that is smart business in 2017 runs the
gamut of obnoxious audacity to downright
stupidity
literally the noble rationale to why I'm
so excited about this investment you
know I'm mainly most excited because
it's not very noble because I think you
can build a big [ __ ] company and I
want to make money but the noble part is
like I genuinely believe in this in a
real way and I don't think it's just you
know a pretty sight mom's that you know
the whole world should be this when I
say it yeah I'm being selfish because I
already know firmly it's going to be and
so like I want the historical I say it
not because of the investment I made the
investment because of it I say it
because I know it's going to happen and
I believe that you guys are operators
and like you will be like when I tell
you that it could end up being a
billion-dollar fashion brand great I I'm
agnostic I just know what's going to
happen he's broken up in a lot of
different ways
Chris's world which is on the improve
course is actually the only one in this
here that's on the influencer team at
vaynermedia proper which works brands
and things that nature gave runs a small
business Gabe runs the division that
charges brands twenty five thirty
thousand dollars a month for doing what
vaynermedia used to do now those four
millions
we're going back to small business we I
wanted him to meet in case some five or
seven or nine months with you guys
decide to do this or we feel like we're
really rolling I feel like we've just
finally got it and an Andy and dunker on
my team it's art but it's math and art
that's what we've built here that's why
this is special it's the first machine
agency that gives a [ __ ] about Zynga and
Nike right it gives a [ __ ] about
LivingSocial and Groupon like it
respects that but also knows that if you
don't make aware is the beef commercial
you're also vulnerable it was all mad so
come back little one a long time ago
yeah got it
come short of everything here are you
sure we're gonna zoom in town that's
awesome
very cool and so how long have you guys
been working together awesome
how did it all start for you I love it
so happen what is like always my kind of
first instinct is there anything you
know I've seen I have contacts for my
sign reaction contactors
is there anything potentially I can help
you guys with anything stand out
anything as you guys are navigating
through this that I could be a help with
like look where his legion I have a
million dollar man action figure here
when he was in wrestling in the 80s he
said everybody's got a price I think
it's important for you to price in a way
that speaks against your strategy here's
what I mean you're being selected with
brands I'm a funny feeling you're going
to spend a lot of times trying to
justify why you like XYZ brand if they
offered you a million dollars for one
pose so what I'm saying there is you
should come up with a spicing strategy
of what's the number that gets you to
start debating and you should actually
price that way because then you have all
the leverage yeah got it
so that would be like pricing strategy
so pearance
you got paid to appear somewhere how
much of that do you want to do or not
one of you I mean a lot of us all
funny-like meet people on hjerson
honestly I think that she should do
whatever the [ __ ] she wants and then
she'll dominate I'm worried that she's
overthinking and holding back certain
[ __ ] that she wants one that I promise I
think that she's holding back a thing or
two she's smart and she understands what
the audience wants so it's not that I
want her to do something it's that I
want her to do what she actually want
I'm doing got it the subtle little thing
there right like I don't think every
woman should be about empowering other
women if that's what they love then they
should do that
like she my left fourth she might like
quiz leaning like I think she just needs
to be her because that would create so
many more avenues and and that's what
that's what the cliche move that people
with your size influence and your genre
and your look aren't doing enough of
which is why they're getting
commoditized it's like hello the media
people and meme accounts if you are
making [ __ ] videos with white tops
and learning you're just come on I've no
idea what you're talkin is they're all
the [ __ ] same shot it like filming
you with three people for a minute in
some sort of business setting or casual
setting more of you the reality TV stars
that are winning the most have a lot of
looks that show would not work if it was
the same scene over and over yeah got it
like there's a lot people like like
there's a clearly a lot potentially for
you to share so it's more of that right
like your version is what I think people
making mistakes up which is they're
picking a platform that's friendly and
they're going with it and they're
winning in the short term in later lose
in the long term right I just want to
know every aspect about her and I want
that in play it's why I'm winning the
motion
[Music]
[Music]
doggy doo-doo you talking [ __ ] gnarling
I got your cool story they yell you
can't deny the simple fact that IRA IRA
and that's what I was dying and since I
could go yeah well after saving I was
like clean before they dogs are you
[ __ ] that me I'm taking it from when
it's done up till the dark a lot now I'm
gonna keep me around and shout out my
[ __ ] growling I got beaten up to beat
until I leave you Phoebe probably not
[Music]
know kind of what's in store for now
[ __ ]
Nathan what are you doing I mean it's
about time you learned something
yeah
[Music]
[Music]
we our meeting and uh I'm seeing Brandon
likey along with my dad is running a
high breakers Gotham not Oh like on good
day sucker you miss a lot all day like
your Yap heard it all before they know
not a what's in store this is a hit out
for the yellow back in on my door mind
everybody I don't say I'm the best I'm
the best here in the world I don't say
that I talk [ __ ] about the most power
which is its the dollar rack you don't
know about the dollar on me and Brandon
to the card show there were these brutal
acts that came out the use of a pardon I
bought a puffer it's like an Isis
sleeping for your table our lives are
our table your Instagram account with
our tables that we rented in a car track
and we would try to make it really good
and I bought this rack and I bought the
dollar rack in and then I put cards that
were worth eighty to a dollar 20 an 80
cents to a dollar 20 and I was really
setting up nice and bring
because the best part of my de freitas
career in sports as a 14 year old was
this is basically the same sitcom every
episode which would be we would show up
once a month for a new show I would have
some cockamamy an idea
it means 7:00 a.m. we've been drinking
like like eating donut and Brandon would
be making fun of the idea of like this
is a super Dan support and his credit
he's like listen your stuff normally
works for this idea pass them and then
and then three hours later in the 11
a.m. and all these people will be at the
Dollar acting alongside three of these
five of these and he would be that could
be anything like perfect play everything
was safe and work and I like dinner from
holiday and all if you nor sputter did I
score out of nowhere my guidance
counselor who never spoke to me I spoke
to her she never spoke to my mom my mom
never spoke to her the only baseball
card show that our high school had in
four years huge it was like it was like
Coachella showing up to your house it
was the only Facebook our trailer at our
high school and they had a Phillies
second baseman Mickey morandini show up
we prepped mentally for month and
physically for week it's the Wednesday
before the show we both say for our
tables and my guidance counselor calls
my mom and tells her that I'm a piece of
[ __ ] I mean I don't know what she said
it but she basically said she basically
said your son has no future
my mom grounds me and doesn't allow me
to do the baseball card show Moran I'll
never forget this you know no cell
phones back then side a wait for Brandon
to come home and I'm crawling the show
with Saturday I'm probably the show is
like from 9 a.m. to 6 p.m. so I'm call I
know even home by 6:30
I'm calling starting at 4:30 maybe
people never you know and the old school
like I called a hundred times finally I
get ahold of them like 755 that night
and he's the best guy I'm like hey hey
he's like how you do like how you doing
I'm like [ __ ] the work how'd it go he
goes I the best say my career I sold
every Frank comics eating for everybody
obviously he just goes not be like
crusting know the end of new career was
the old bridge fires thank you you're
out we do remember when I talked I mean
wrecking you pregnant there's where I
talk about I sold all my cards and
bought toys and common dresses
the show where I fail man with the end
of his career so we do yourself it's at
a fire station in a small town - Oh
Brandon I had this Saturday he's setting
up his cards I start opening up these
boxes and stuff with your is certify and
Catwoman toys break again if there were
juniors in high school when it looks
over hey
I'm not I go this is an Urkel and I do
second time I [ __ ] remember as a
steps nobody thought about Marvel movies
and Star Wars
I [ __ ] nailed it but when juniors a
place Bullock we now care about girls
like we're like different now I'm
breathing barely holding on
baseball cards so that's nerdy and
masculine and here I have like the crazy
I'm I I'm including omits a smurfalator
like Gargamel what's drama we give this
show means pin and the owner of a
baseball card store in his town so
here's the real dealer in the middle I'm
gonna write bread and to the left we
have so many classics from that story
well including I bought a case of shitty
nineteen ninety dollars card and they
both [ __ ] on me
they were like laughing at me when I
bought the case I bought the head case
for like forty dollars there was like
ten boxes of twenty nine twenty bucks
180 I'm sorry I bought the whole box for
eighty dollars and it was the worst set
of all time Bernie Williams was the best
card and it was a salary so I biking oh
my god I can't 20 boxes worth and then I
took a syllabic and I ready fun genre
1919 a replica Bernie Williams
rookie resume and then who will know if
I cannot and I was like Ricky they're
fine I'm in and then I wrote this is
where live your boss's wife I wrote nice
when I was at Excel my dollars a box
literally like it wasn't worth the
dollar and then I put it and then the
block and they were like when I tell you
the two of them were like literally like
schoolgirls a toccata like out of like a
playground being like like it had no
chance literally over the next three
hours the
back boxes I'll take a lot talking about
talking about talking about our way
creative is a variable of success NATO
is a variable of success I would take a
picture and post it on my mouth wave
everything the same thesis which is how
do you stop somebody he's busy and has
choices how do you stop them from other
options and pick you and that's what I
do in a feat right why do people stop
the my shin on Instagram great night
with Brannon
supposed to get a blind library where
some book talks about cold place for
hard war stories we rock on you have to
basically added that entire baseball
hard water into a video because we need
that for history
Brandon's kids need to know what kind of
warrior he was good night battle my son
good day feeling good nothing else it's
a beautiful thing when a when a loser
gets to live his dreams you know
especially when you think not many of us
video game dudes who end up like me and
I mean it's hard being a teen and just
thinking like [ __ ] I want to sing but I
guess it's weird and I should have
something to fear because I was writing
plays instead of pounding beers I told
God tell me what you want me to be and
I'll be it there's a light and I see it
so where it's true you know do these
tunes and awkward dance moves I can show
to you
[Music]